Like pathogens.
Cancer cells evolve ways of evading or suppressing the immune system.
In fact,
the immune system is quite effective at suppressing most abnormal cell growth.
And so cancers almost by definition consists of that tiny fraction of abnormal
cells that have managed to evade or suppress the immune system.
Cancer cells have the same genotype as the other cells in the body,
so they are modified self.
That means that the pose a special problem for the immune system,
which is not supposed to attack self.
The immune system has many mechanisms that will ensure that it doesn't.
The tech self immune responses to cancer are an attack on self cells that have
pathological characteristics.
They have inappropriate metabolism,
inappropriate growth,
or inappropriate movement.
Okay.
The immune system consists of set of s of sets of cells,
each that have specific functions that are coordinated by multiple signals,
whose meaning is interpreted by specific sets of receptors.
So that is the enemy of the cancer cell.
Cancer's evade that enemy.
They evade the immune responses by disrupting those cells,
those signals and those receptors.
Those are the same options that are used by pathogens.
So to begin,
most tumors are eliminated,
some survive,
but are kept under control and a few escape.
But progress to cancer
elimination is done by recognizing and killing.
And that's done by both DNA and by the adaptive immune system.
Some cancers escape elimination but remained small because there are kept under
immune pressure.
They're not clinically detectable.
We can each contain many such precancerous growth.
Yeah,
escape and progression to cancer results.
When the immune system is either inhibited or no longer effective due to
mutations in cancer cells that are altering their properties.
So how does cancer deal with one major enemy?
The NK,
the natural killer cells,
they're part of the innate immune system.
They can react to pathogens,
pathogens into tumors quickly with or without priming.
By antibodies.
They have a repertoire of receptors that insurer insures self tolerance while
allowing reactions to pathogens and the cancer cells.
Yeah.
Nk cells are this a major problem for cancer cells because they are activated
when triggered by signals from distressed or transformed cells and they then
kill them.
So here we see some of their biological functions here,
a healthy cell,
and if it has DNA damage or is being by mutations into a tumor,
or if it has an internal cytoplasmic bacterial infection,
then it becomes a stress target cell.
So it changes shape
and a natural killer cell can then cause cell lysis and it can coat this cell.
If the cell was,
has been coated with antibodies,
it will signal to macrophages and does he sells and they can then eliminate the
distress target cell.
It can also present antigen.
The natural killer cell can present antigen to a dendritic cell,
which then can go into a standard dendritic t-cell recruitment cycle and that
will lead to the recruitment of t cells that will eliminate the stress target
cells.
So in case cells are involved in eliminating stress cells that are either killed
directly by lysis or indirectly by activating t cells and macrophages,
the natural killer cells,
the NK cells need to integrate a number of signals to determine how they're
going to respond.
They have activating uh,
signals and then there are also signals that suppress them and they have
receptors for both sides.
So it's a balance of plus and minus and these are MHC receptors.
Okay.
So it,
there are activating and inhibiting receptors.
They natural killer cells attack cells that are downregulating MHC one and they
attack cells that are expressing stress signals.
So it is a balance of a number of different kinds of signals coming into
receptors on natural killer cells that result in there attacking and killing.
How can this auto immune response be subverted by a cancer cell?
Okay.
There are certain t reg cells,
the CD four plus and CD 25 plus t regs that suppress autoimmune responses.
So they inhibit immune cells that would attack self,
that would attack cancer.
Tumor cells secrete a cytokine to or growth factor Beta that converts these t
regs
okay.
From plus minus and the plus plus
leads us convert a population of immune cells.
They would otherwise mediate attacks on them into cells that are ineffective,
thereby evading immune surveillance.
Neutralizing tour growth factor,
Beta derived from tumor cells blocked this conversion.
And that essentially meant that the immune system remained capable of attacking
the cancer.
Tumors can also modify their metabolism in ways that suppress cytotoxic or
antigen presenting cells so they can modify their metabolism so that they can
interfere with the defense mechanisms being deployed against them.
They deal with low oxygen by operating upregulating glycolysis.
This lowers the Ph in the tumor microenvironment.
So you should think that of of both oxygen becoming scarce and the environment
becoming more acidic,
tumor cells are then directly competing for glucose with glycolytic immune
cells.
So they're taking away the food from the immune cells.
The lowered Ph interferes with the maturation and activation of cytotoxic t
cells and antigen presenting cells.
So they are slowing the growth and differentiation of the immune system that
would attack them.
So two hallmarks of cancer,
which are altered glucose metabolism and immune suppression may be linked
together.
Yeah.
The upregulation of glycolysis is producing a cascade of effects on the cells of
the adaptive immune system.
So cancer cells are increasing,
their glycolytic pathway is causing ph to drop.
Uh,
it's also inducing angiogenesis.
The t cells are being down regulated by that
and
there are interferon gamma gamma's that are a cytokine produced by both the
natural killer cells and by the cytotoxic t cells.
Interferon gamma activates macrophages and modulates the differentiation of t
helper cells and regulatory t cells.
So if the Ph is dropping,
then interferon gamma is being suppressed and this process is not occurred.
The hypoxia inducible factors,
the Hii F's
are transcription factors that respond to decreases in oxygen in the
environment.
The vascular endothelial growth factor,
that's veg f there is a protein signal that stimulates angiogenesis and the mds
sees in the diagram or myeloid immunosuppressive cells that increase up to 10
fold in cancer patients.
So this is a pathway where simply by altering Ph and suppressing the secretion
of certain factors,
cells can be recruited that in fact suppressed immune response,
thus protecting cancer cells from attacks on the immune system.
So part of it,
part of the defense of cancer against attack by the immune system is simple
changes in the biochemical environment,
in the nutritional environment of the cells.
Okay?
No tumor cells also down regulate expression of MHC one but they don't down
regulate it too much.
Viruses also do this.
Some downregulation allows them to avoid the adaptive immune response that comes
from cytotoxic t cells.
But continuing to express a low level of MHC one protects them from an attack by
natural killer cells.
These are mechanisms that are quite similar to the ones used by viruses that to
avoid detection and destruction.
So this is convergent evolution that's hit upon both by viruses and by cancer
cells to keep from getting killed by cells in the immune system.
To summarize,
most precancerous growths are detected and destroyed.
Some remain,
but they do not grow and are not detecting.
Those that escape and progress to cancer are the ones that are either suppressed
or that evaded immune immune surveillance.
They can do so with several mechanisms.
They can disable natural killer cells,
they can subvert the auto immune response.
They can modify their metabolism to interfere with the immune response and they
can down regulate the expression of MHC one
plus.
They resembled pathogens in their manipulative ability.